John isn't really my father son is the
son of Rhaegar Targaryen and my aunt
Lyanna Stark he was born in a tower in
Dorne his last name isn't really snow
John's real name
hey everybody as requested this is gonna
be my aegon targaryen video why is such
a big deal that that's jon snow's name
now that we're sliding into the
offseason if you are finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there will be Game of Thrones
happening every week and when we get to
the books if there are books that are
released next year we can decide what
kind of videos to do for that too so on
the TV show we finally found out that
jon snow's true name is Aegon Targaryen
he's a legitimate son of Rhaegar and
Lyanna meaning that he's not a bastard
although there's a lot of contention
over the last name sand that bran gave
him we'll discuss that but there are a
couple of important egg ons
in the book so it gets a little
confusing in a really important
historical Aegon so this will be all
about the four different versions of
Aegon and sort of the deeper meaning
that that is Jon Snow's name in what it
would be if he actually became king of
the Seven Kingdoms by himself or with
Daenerys right now you could just call
him Aegon but if he actually sat on the
throne his formal name would be Aegon
the sixth just because he's the sixth
Aegon to sit on the throne so the
commonly held belief is that it was
actually Liana that chose to name him
Aegon whether or not Rhaegar had that in
mind before he went to the Trident
because you have to remember that
Rhaegar had ridden for the Trident was
killed by Robert Baratheon before Jon
Snow was actually born that's why the
Kingsguard were still at the Tower of
joy because one Rhaegar wanted to
protect his new wife and child because
they were precious to him but also
because he believed that Jon Snow or
Aegon Targaryen however you want to
think about him was the child of
prophecy now you could also say that he
was thinking that he would be the crown
prince should Rhaegar died but I don't
think that he truly believed that he
would die at the Trident and there are a
lot of other crazy decisions that
Rhaegar may he was obsessed with
prophecy so if there's any reason why he
left the best sword in the Kingdom
Arthur Dayne protecting that baby it's
because of the prophecy there's a lot of
people that have been back and forth on
how crazy Rhaegar was and what kind of a
person he was based on what sir
Barristan Selmy has said about him and
based on what other people have said but
all we know is that he was a little bit
crazy and really in love with Lyanna
stark but you have to remember that he
also set aside his other wife Elia
Martell with his others
son who was also named Aegon Targaryen
so we'll talk about the other egg ons in
a second but the reason why lianna
probably chose the name Aegon is is
because of Aegon the conquerer because
it was the name of the most famous
person in the history of Westeros and
his ancestor so it was just a really
popular name like I said he would have
been Aegon the six so it was a really
popular name just in the line of
succession you have to imagine that
there were all kinds of Targaryen
cousins that were also probably named
Aegon that just weren't anywhere near
the throne so you have to imagine that
in regards mine this prince who was
promised would be like what Daenerys has
right now the person with the three
dragons like Aegon the conquerer he
would save us all from the long night so
because he was so obsessed with the
culmination of this prophecy he set
aside his other wife Elia Martell with
his two other children Rhaenys and then
Aegon so the whole idea is that he
wanted three children in the maesters
said that Elia Martell wouldn't be able
to have a third child so that sounds
like the point at which he bailed and
went and married Lyanna stark and had
the child with her so here's the funny
thing he actually expected Jon Snow to
be born a woman or at least hoped that
because think about it this way he
already had a son named Aegon and
rayna's and he was all about bringing
back Aegon the conquerer this person of
prophecy the prince who was promised who
was a Gon's
other sister it was Visenya so that's
probably what he would have named Jon
Snow had he been born a woman and he
would have gotten his three children
that's what he wanted the dragon must
have three heads and he wanted it to be
a repeat of Aegon the conquerer with his
three dragons so poor Jon Snow just
can't catch a break I guess that also
means that Rhaegar would have expected
his other baby Aegon with Elia Martell
to marry his two sisters that would have
been a little bit weird if you think
that Jon Snow and Daenerys on the TV
show is weird now it would have been
even weirder if it would have been like
Aegon the conquerors two sister wives so
that's sort of the reason why Jon Snow
has named Aegon whether or not Liana
came up with that by herself or whether
Rhaegar helped her come to that name she
was the one who actually named it so
most people give her credit for the name
Aegon but what about the other two
Hagen's in modern day so you have the
son of Elia and Rhaegar who became a
bastard when he anoles his marriage to
Elia there's a lot of questions about
what would have happened to them had
they survived and not being killed by
the mountain at the end of Robert's
rebellion even though they would have no
longer been Royals they would have been
royal bastards so they still would have
been kept in the life of luxury in
King's Landing somewhere or somewhere
nearby because being a royal bastard is
still relatively distasteful but it's
much better than being a bastard of a
lesser house you don't get spit on quite
as much so what happened is is everyone
believed that that version of Aegon who
was only about a year old at the end of
Robert's rebellion was killed by the
mountain and people just believed that
he was dead like the mountain dashed him
against the wall and that was the end of
it but many years later in the book sort
of in present day this young Griff
character comes forward Jon connington
Illyrio in varus back him as the true
son of Rhaegar no no no we switched the
baby out the one that the mountain
killed was a fake this is actually a gan
son of Rhaegar in there presenting him
is still legitimate because in the books
people haven't revealed whether or not
Rhaegar married Liana so even though the
books are still doing R plus L equals J
there's still this Aegon that's come
along and said no no no I'm still alive
and I'm the true heir to the Iron Throne
not Daenerys not any of these other
people for a long time people suspected
that he might be a Blackfyre secretly so
even though he has some Targaryen blood
he's not the son of Rhaegar and Elia
Martell he's actually the son of Illyrio
Inserra who was kind of a prostitute but
might be related to malice Blackfyre
last to the Blackfyre pretenders so he
still has a little bit of the blood of
the dragon inside of him but is very
decently removed has no legitimate claim
to the throne and is not actually Aegon
Targaryen whatever his real name
actually is they just call him young
Griff so we've referred to Varys going
to Daenerys and trying to put her back
on the throne as the Targaryen
restoration in the books beerus has just
gone to this other Aegon character and
it sounds like he's a bit of a champion
time waster and we'll find out that it's
a failed bid for the throne and then
eventually Varys will jump to team
Daenerys so all this Jon connington
young Griff stuff in the books will
lead to nowhere but those are the other
two a Gon's in modern-day it's really
one Aegon pretending to be the other
Aegon so technically you should say
there's only two a Gon's in modern-day
one of them was Elia Martell and Rhaegar
son he died the other one that's not Jon
Snow is just pretending to be that dead
baby but hopefully that explains who all
the Aegon czar and what's going on with
the young Griff character in the son of
Elia Martell and Rhaegar he would have
actually kept the name Aegon but he
wouldn't have been Aegon the sixth any
more Jon Snow would have actually had
the rights to that name you would have
just called Elia Martell son Aegon and
that'd be the end of it
he wouldn't get the extra little bit at
the end of it because he probably would
have never sat on the Iron Throne but as
the show is implied Jon Snow is
eventually going to learn the truth of
the matter everyone else around him -
what will they call him will they still
call him Jon will they start calling him
Aegon the actor that plays brand who was
actually talking about how this is going
to be revealed suggested that it might
be Samwell to reveal the information to
Jon Snow
but that the other star children won't
think of him any differently he'll still
be their brother Jon Snow so I think
they're a good barometer for how most
people will treat him they won't think
of him that much differently it'll just
get a little more complicated especially
for Jon Snow and Daenerys but honestly
the rest of the realm will probably just
think of him as the king of the north
they won't say Aegon the king of the
north or Jon Snow King in the north
they'll just be like Cersei and shorten
it to King in the north
because sir she's still gonna be queen
for most of season eight we'll see how
she goes down now a lot of you have
asked for a death predictions video in
season eight the funny thing to say is
that everybody should die but obviously
I'll do a video for that because I think
there's gonna be a certain order to it
in there some people that I'm hundred
percent sure are gonna die in there a
couple people I think will be able to
crawl away but if you have any other
Aegon or history videos that you guys
want me to do let me know in the
comments I'll do more character videos
next week and there will be a new video
tomorrow I'll probably rank all the
episodes and I'll continue to do Q&A
videos but they'll probably wind up
being for more specific things than just
general episodes but congratulations to
the new giveaway winner Mike Oliver
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there'll be a new round
when I post my new video tomorrow
what you wait for that click here for
all my season 8 predictions and you can
click here to learn all about why
Daenerys might be able to get pregnant
again on the TV show thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you